i myself am heaven and hell
be happy for this moment this moment is
your life
the thoughtful soul to solitude retires
a hair divides what is false and true
strange is it not that of the myriads
who before us pass the door of darkness
through not one returns to tell us of
the road which to discover we must
travel to
heaven but the vision of fulfilled
desire and held a shadow from a soul on
fire
cast on the darkness into which
ourselves
so late emerged from shall so soon
expire
there was a door to which i found no key
there was the veil through which i might
not see
ah make the most of what yet we may
spend before we two into dust descend
each morn a thousand roses brings you
say yes but where leaves the rose of
yesterday
drink for you know not whence you came
nor why drink
for you know not why you go nor where
a book a woman and a flask of wine the
three make heaven for me it may be thine
is some sour place of singing cold and
bear but then i never said thy heaven
was mine
when i want to understand what is
happening today or try to decide what
will happen tomorrow i look back
ah my beloved fill the cup that clears
today past regrets and future fears
tomorrow why tomorrow i may be
myself with yesterday is 7 000 years
i sent my soul through the invisible
some letter of that after life to spell
and by and by my soul returned to me and
answered i myself am heaven and hell
the wine of life keeps oozing drop by
drop
the leaves of life keep falling one by
one
living life tomorrow's fate though thou
be wise thou canst not tell nor yet
surmise
pass therefore not today in vain for it
will never come again
we are no other than a moving row of
magic shadow shapes that come and go
oh threats of hell in hopes of paradise
one thing at least is certain this life
flies one thing is certain and the rest
is lies
the flower that once has blown forever
dies
myself when young did eagerly frequent
doctor and saint and heard great
argument about it and about but evermore
came out by the same door as in i went
waste not your hour nor in the vain
pursuit of this and that endeavor and
dispute
better be jockened with the fruitful
grape then sadden after none or bitter
fruit
by the help of god and with his precious
assistance i say that algebra is a
scientific art
the objects with which it deals are
absolute numbers in measurable
quantities which though themselves
unknown are related to things which are
known whereby the determination of the
unknown quantities is possible
you